let's do battle again I'll give him a
second chance if I went again then it's
just he's intimidated
he is the intimidation is this computer
intimidated fear it
fear fear that Bishop stick around this
computer will be shutting me up very
soon very soon I can't be too happy I'm
just gonna call to he I know a lot will
question how do you know it's he why do
you say he are they or all that stuff I
got this though he's got nothing he's
got nothing boom
juicy knight on d5 come on this is like
this is like no competition now Knight
b6 to d5 trade off late night b6 trade
LightScribe bishops plant my knight here
everybody's happy night here Bishop
check I could take and if Knight g5 I
could take again I'm on the Queen let's
go Knight b6 I'm not afraid of that
let's get these guys off 95 good night
vs. bad bishop clean here Queen here
Queen trade I might be able to get this
let me get a pair of rooks off the board
first I made a stupid move a couple of
streams are not streams ago I wasn't
playing one I wasn't playing the
computer a while I was on the stream
it's been a while since I did that but
what am I getting at I traded off too
many I only want to trade off up one
pair of Brooks I only traded off both
pairs and I had a bad ending with the
night versus my the computer is really
good Bishop so I want to
a bit careful I think it's important to
get off one pair of rooks and now just
centralize my knight or what about f6
King f7 that rules out any Knight pivots
I think there's something to be said for
that so it's certainly a little bit
vulnerable along this diagonal but I
could always block it with tonight here
so I think King up and now I'm in a spot
to just trade a bunch and in this ending
I think I stand well except if there's
that move but wait a second knight
Knight h4l has some my tension queen
here off for a queen exchange if Queen
check I could block with my queen I
think I have all the key squares covered
Queen trade please repetition oh we're
having a Queen trade rook here's so I
can move my knight
it's a little awkward not much time mmm
I would like to have my like rook d7 a4
is happening though
and then rook d7 a5 I don't really want
to allow that pawn to get too far down
but maybe it's okay
I'm gonna try that or no wait the bishop
could pin the night I want to hang on to
my tricky Knight not that my opponent
would be tricked let's just do this post
up night my king wants to walk over here
but first I don't want this night to
play here to attack my pawn so let's do
this before my Jeep on becomes a
liability and now this then sneak over
here I can make me backup my bishop one
day
oh that Knights gonna play there what a
bug I got to do this I think my rook is
gonna be kicked away at some point with
Knight f5 Bishop f4 no not really no
that wouldn't happen I don't have to do
that just yet King here I think is okay
Knight here I back up my bishop let's
keep him around um King here there's
still no bishop thing King here rook
over here a minute 40 seems a little
weird to do this why am I not moving
that pond actually that was stupid I
just moved that yeah no we're gonna have
to deal with that aren't we let's come
back over here
Oh 124 this is tough I gotta come over
here there's Knight checks I could play
King here I think okay I'm doing this I
want to get my pawn to a4 I get that oh
crap let's do this
where's this night going tricky night
tricky night 110 ah man this thing is
gonna make me fight for everything my
bishops there defend please get out of
forks and stuff if I gotta do this I
think ah 52 seconds I don't have any
time sound familiar
I'm out of any time I just want the
rooks off trade rooks please computer
get out of there never a repetition come
over here 46 seconds oh now I'm in a pen
the King needs to come over come on this
is a draw you know it's a draw
yeah making any progress Oh until you
make that move is this a defense can I
hold this somehow then it's gonna be
taken like this can I hold this 35
seconds ah man I don't know what I would
do
King here get out of there get out of my
house 26 man so tough so tough get out
of there rook you're gonna try and
skewer me I know what you're up to
you're up to no good 18 on the hang out
of my knight he's awesome can I hold
draw here no this isn't gonna be a draw
maybe it's stupid in the ending it might
be stupid 12 seconds I don't have any
time I'm gonna get pushed around now uh
check blockade can I get a blockade
point eight seconds it's just gonna sack
upon and stuff it's making I'm dead on
time and possess
yeah you should win your computer okay
we're even I'm lucky to even be even I
should quit while I'm even it's gonna be
behind very soon